join my day Joe Rogan podcast by night
all day
now you developed a really unusual
fighting style I mean I think I've said
about you that one of the more unusual
things about your style is that I could
watch you like as a silhouette someone
could show me a silhouette of you moving
around I go out that's Dominick Cruz
there's very few people that you would
say that about like where you would
instantaneously recognize their
movements like your movements are very
unusual very difficult to pattern and
they're not really indicative of like a
style like you know there's the Muay
thai-style people have that light front
leg does the karate style like you know
wonderboy Thompson there's a bunch of
styles where you go oh I see what this
guys doing your style is very uniquely
yours
what what what sort of cause that
where'd that come from it's a mixture of
things as I mean I've been fighting
since as long as the Diaz brothers I
started when I was 19 years old back in
2005 and I've been doing it since then
so that's part of it is that just years
and years of fighting and facing
different people and seeing what the
issues were but more not it was built
around the fact that I knew whether I
whether whether I like knew I was ahead
or not my minds have said I have to
fight do something different because
this is a new sport with new rules and
new different equipment than has ever
been seen in the history of this world
so that means there's four ounce gloves
we're using kicks knees elbows and hands
everything right ollie
all eight limbs so I said I need to make
sure that I'm not taking damage as long
as I'm not taking damage I should win I
got to be hard to hit on my defense it
needs to be flawless with these size
gloves it's not going to be the same as
boxing I can't just sit here and cover
like this because my gloves are a
quarter the size of things peek in and I
learned that real quick and so I said
all right so I need to move non-stop I
can't sit still like I do in boxing or
kickboxing because you're going to get
taken down as well so that's that's
where my mind started changing is with
the takedown that's where I knew I
really had to do something different is
in no striking
or on earth is there a takedown involved
so that means that I need to attack on a
different plane and that means I need to
not be down the center line as long as
that fight not down the center line it
takes away as long as I don't fight on
the center line all the time it takes
away almost all weapons from all styles
boxing is probably the one style that
flows most off this center line but
we're talking about Muay Thai or we're
talking about wrestling we're talking
about judo or we're talking about it
almost every other martial arts they
attack down a straight line and so I
knew I could take away most of their
weapons just by changing the plane that
I fought on if I fought on a different
plane than them then they would not have
answers for the plane that I'm fighting
because everything they do is on that
line so instead of fighting them and
their style like fought the lines that
they're fighting on and then that kind
of changed things mixed with the defense
well I've always enjoyed watching the
fight and I've always enjoyed explaining
how you fight two people that have never
seen martial arts you don't understand
it because four people on the outside
maybe someone who's not a fan or never
did any martial arts training they look
at it like just violence you know they
see guys just beating the [ __ ] out of
each other
and what would I the way I try to
describe it to a friend once I said
think about it this way it's it's a lot
like a conversation and the more words
you have at your disposal the more
verbal memory you have the more used to
stringing together sentences you are the
more fluently the conversation is going
to come out of your mouth the more it's
going to flow right and when you're
watching and then I'll show someone like
you when you're trying to have you know
which call it a conversation trying to
have a conversation with Dominick Cruz
inside the Octagon
you don't know where the [ __ ] is going
like you you're setting up so many weird
angles and so much weird moves so many
false entries and there's so much going
on that you're in a lot of ways you're
overloading a person's reactions yeah
you're overloading their mind
well that is partially what I'm trying
to do yes I'd agree no you're starting
to see that over time there's an answer
for every style there's an answer for
everything yeah and that's the fun of
this thing is it's not always stagnant
is not always the same
and there there isn't answer to
everything that's and then you got to
adjust right so that's what I'm built on
is adjustments my whole game is built on
adjustments so it can always change and
always look different because every
round I come out with a different
adjustment off of what you did to me and
now you're fighting a different guy
every round you just don't know it but
that comes from fakes and seeing what
they want on you and that comes from
their game plan it's a whole mixture
reads in there and that that's like
that's something that you either have
you don't have you know something like
Anderson Silva can make reads extremely
quickly
right and that's what's made them so
successful Demetrius Johnson reads
extremely quickly makes them successful
the best in the world adjust and the
best for me the best in the world aren't
the ones who just win it's someone to
win and stay on top for a long period of
time right because now you don't just
have a style to win a fight you have a
style to stay winning which means that
your style hits so many different
avenues that you can compete with all
these different styles no matter what
they match you up against until now my
style
I built it so that no matter which style
you try to throw at me
it was going to give it a problem and
that was the basis that I wanted to
create when I plot every single time
I've fought somebody it was it doesn't
matter what your gift is the planes that
I'm going to fight you on make it
impossible for your gifts to be your
gifts anymore now I've seen you practice
and I've seen your footwork drills and
I've seen you know a lot of your steps
and the different various entries you
have techniques are these moves that
you've learned from somewhere have you
acquired them from other martial arts
have you sort of it adjusted them and
adapted them or did you figure them out
your own it's been a mixture working
with Eric del Ferro was a huge step
because I had a lot of matches one of
the best coaches in the sport and one of
the most underappreciated guys because
doesn't blow his own horn that's why I
love him I liked the coaches that don't
need to pass on the back for themselves
right about the athlete Eric is about
every lastly he's ever coached he's not
about himself
you have great corner man too when he
starts talking in the corner jungles and
he's been in this sport 20-plus years
and
um the bigger thing that Eric doesn't
get credit for is his understanding of
the psychology that goes into preparing
somebody to win a fight you could have
all the tools around that person they
could be the best human being on earth
but if their mind is not pieced together
the psychological pieces are not there
you're not going to be able to trigger
them and get them in the fight when you
need to Jeremy Stephen is a great
example of somebody like that sometimes
you got to like get crazy with that dude
in the corner and like even like slap
him around a little bit maybe and he
just goes and he'll kill somebody it's
like there's a psychological thing about
certain athletes that you have to be
able to touch on same with Greg Jackson
is another guy who can do that and
that's what makes a good coach on that
night a good corner man on that night
not just what you did for eight weeks
holding pads and you know patting the
guy in the back and wiping the sweat off
their shoulders and you know doing
interviews and looking famous with them
like what are you doing to make sure
this person wins on that night not what
are you doing to make sure you look good
in this person's corner while he wins
right and not something that I've run
into a lot with people is people a lot
want to associate themselves with you
when you're winning and not actually be
there for you but be there so they look
good in your corner while you win and
those are the people you got to cut out
those are the yes myth no those are the
ones you got to be careful with Eric is
the opposite of that and he's somebody
that's why I stick with them me someday
I can trust he understands my psychology
he understands my the emotional
rollercoaster of outside lying lot and
very effectively that will always be my
argument with every conventional coach
and this is a lie I break what makes
them relevant well it's not necessarily
you break what makes them relevant you
figure out a way to make your style work
in a way that confounds the expert well
what I mean by that is when they talk to
me well like maybe not 220 million other
people they are the [ __ ] right but when
you try to tell me that and you I've had
I can't tell you how many countless
world champion kickboxing coaches go
only you can do that you're awesome keep
doing it and ice and I couldn't disagree
more well anybody can do it if they
mimic your movements and your movements
aren't like Cirque de Soleil movements
that you have to be like physically
gifted in order to pull off or I'm
working towards them for a hundred years
yeah
not going to see her and break it down
but there are obviously movements that
I'm going and they can be read it took
30 rounds to figure out with the same
camp for ten years but they figured it
out right
you know i thinkin they can imitate you
is she justin Buchholz do ya they do
pretty well know what they're doing but
with who else has fought somebody as
much as they fought me I mean write
about it Benavides twice saber twice TJ
Dillashaw Charlie Valencia has fought
with them Scott Jorgensen trained with
them before him even the call train with
them for a tiny bit of time before him
essentially every single person I've
ever fought for the past 10 years has at
some point been friends a favor train
with that camp because they were the
little guy camp while I said why join
him if you can beat him and I just did
it my own way and let them all hate me
and train together and it was ok with me
you know I needed to do things my way in
order to build something different in a
game that hadn't really caught up to the
things that I was thinking about yet in
my opinion it didn't make me the only
one that was writing these things is
just how I used to things that I used
they had theirs too but my whole mindset
was like I said if I fight like them I'm
going to be like them and they're going
to adjust to me like they adjust
everybody else now going back to the
early days when you sort of learn the
style we kind of got off this but I
really wanted to touch back on it when
you said that your style no one had your
style before no one could tell you that
it you know was the wrong way to do it
because you're being very effective with
it but did you take it from anywhere did
you look at boxing footage did you look
at kickboxing or Muay Thai like where
did you get all your footwork from well
there's a mixture things one so it all
started with me fighting at 155 pounds
wing 142 pounds that's where this whole
mindset started so it was there already
twice as big as you and on Friday
they're going to be three times as big
as you so you better not get touched you
better not get grabbed and you better
not get hit at all don't let them touch
you because they're too big they take
you down your energy is going to be
zapped by the time you do get up if you
get up and if they hit you they're big
and strong and they're probably gonna
put you out so you have to use all that
strength all that size again
them and make it their weakness instead
of their strength and that's how I
started because I was so little that I
said all right I need to focus on
defense obviously I gotta hurt them too
but after they do what they're trying to
do with their big strength and be
stronger and be more powerful and be
more athletic they're going to wear
themselves out and then I do now were
even around middle around to all those
things that they had early were even
though and now I can just out think them
and pick them apart and beat them and I
always had that mentality rather than
fight fire with fire it just didn't make
sense to me when my body was on the line
I wanted the path of least resistance
and so it started with that until I got
to about five and fought in total combat
I took that fight on two days notice
went out there with no coaches no
cornermen and went by myself and they
just picked cornermen random cornermen
and put him in out there that night was
why Eric liked me because he saw you
know I took it short notice won it it
was a tough fight but I had no qualms
and I came solo on a flight just went
and so he's like okay I can work with
this you know this guy wants to do it so
he picked me up but then that's really
when the progression started meeting
Eric like and that's because I'd never
had I mean I had pals held for me here
and there in Tucson but only if guys
were getting 65 bucks to do it or
something for it because there's not a
lot of money in fight game so they're
all as hungry as I am the trainer's and
I wasn't really like some star pupil
that everybody wanted to get on board
and make a world champion at this point
I was just a guy right so I wasn't
getting pad work I wasn't getting
one-on-one training I lined up my own
coaching I'd have guys that knew what
they were doing being pro boxers Pro
high-level wrestlers high level blue
belts at this time and roll and wrestle
and make my own team in my own coaches
with the people that I had available but
I didn't have a head and when I found
Eric at 6 and I won that fight found
Eric and he said I'll coach you I'll get
you a manager and I'll get all this
figured out for you that's what I was
really looking for that's why I went to
California and got out of twosomes
because I knew I wasn't finding that in
Tucson hmm when I went there and got
that it was like a gift I was like this
is what I'm talking about
I knew if I went there and won with no
one in my corner somebody would want to
pick me up and they did Eric kid
can we state he had ever since so was
your style something that you worked on
with Eric like learning those footwork
drills like when when you came to him
you essentially were a smaller guy who
was fighting bigger guys and had to be a
little trickier in your movement where
were you getting that stuff from well
now when I meet Eric I'm no longer as a
smaller guy fighting bigger guys because
well a little bit but forty five and
thirty forty five is now allowed now 145
pounds is just getting into these small
shells not just the WEC so by the time I
meet Eric at six and oh I'm I take that
fight on two days notice at 145 pounds
but I was getting ready to fight at 155
in Colorado for a world title but the
whole show got canceled that's why I was
in shape to take the fight on two days
notice so when I met Eric the 45 pound
weight class is their 55 was what the
one that was basking so that's that was
how I got into the UFC but your question
exactly was what was how did you devise
your movement how did you divide you
footwork did you study other stuff did
you learn it with Eric did you guys put
it together
honestly like I had a couple things that
I did naturally and then Eric and Eric
has a skill set where he if you have a
natural movement he doesn't tell you to
fix it he lets you do it and then turns
it in as you add a weapon to it that's
his gift and I had a lot of those little
weird odd things that I did and those
weird odd things you had just devised to
learn how to ollie from bigger people
yeah there's a mixture of wrestling
stance with punching and kicking I kind
of have a if you watch wrestling that
there's no set stance
there's no set well you know what I mean
you know if you watch college high
school like the highest level wrestlers
it's all fluent motion in both stances
so I made fighting that because I
started out wrestling and then I added
the punches and the kicks to that moves
to that motion instead of trying to
change what I already did with my
wrestling and try to make it this way he
just let me do what I did up to five
Andoh with my wrestling in whatever I
myself and then he just tightened it up
and made it into a pro level look to an
extent speed timing range these type of
things and now what do you have it now
as a system
do you have it organized I have it
written down no I have a system but I'm
a visual learner so you could you can
literally just do a movement in front of
me and I'll learn it really quick but if
you write it or I had to read it I'll
never get it it's I'm all visual so I
just there's certain things that I was
running into when I would spar early on
starting that I came up with habits to
deal with because of my wrestling in my
and and not having a coach that instead
of the coach saying no do this I just
adjusted and found my own answers when
do you keep a training log of all these
lessons that you learned no I know you
they're just all in your mind yeah I
know I know I know them very well
and decided it hundred percent confident
you keep that stuff in your memory you
don't need to write it down no I don't
need to write it down because I drill it
right and once I have a memory I don't
just write I do it I drill it pad work a
shell Eric and I'll say what you think
about this and he'll be like okay will I
do this and this to make it a little
better and keep you done it okay and we
use it but I mean I'm using I'm not
using the craziest moves in the world
you know John Jones used crazy moves on
certain people like Stephens Stephen
Thompson throws has crazy moves you know
what I mean you know I'm actually using
crazy movements to stay defensive and
offensive simultaneously mm-hmm that's
that's the idea to do both at the same
time and to be very hard to read
well you're hard to read if you're being
offensive and defensive at the same you
know yeah it's hard to read because you
don't know if I'm being offensive or
defensive it's one or the other or both
I can do both because where I put myself
I'm defensively in a generally speaking
when I would have been doing very well
in my matchups I put myself in the in
the gray area where even if you do hit
me it's limited power and I'm still able
to hit you more and you're able to hit
me basically that's the idea now
literally
[Music]